all right hey what's going on it's bill
bird it's time for the Monday morning
podcast from Monday April 20th 2020
what's going on how are you if you just
listen to the audio this probably just
sounds like the normal podcast but if
you guys are on the YouTube channel I
finally filmed one I have a very special
guest on the podcast here during these
these these weird times whatever the
[ __ ] they're saying we have al Jerguson
from ministry who has a new single
coming out called alert level that ones
that come out out I think Friday Friday
so that's twenty fourth Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday yeah 24th
April 24th comes out April 24th so you
look like you're in the [ __ ] Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame you got all these
guitars hanging behind you did you just
get nominated for something no this is
not why I'm here I'm here because I'm
working I'm in the studio I'm doing a
new album man and this is like I can
just grab one and play when I'm
recording so this is not like some
showcase things it's a practical
functional thing that's awesome because
in my house those would be all hanging
on the wall and I wouldn't be able to
play any of them the classic dad weekend
guitar player so I always wondered about
that you know you guys who actually pro
musicians and stuff like that so you
have all of that out front that I resent
that I was an out of go musician you're
not I know I'm an artist I put things
together it's just like you know like I
think like Kooks get all the credit all
these celebrity chefs but like the prep
cooks are the ones that do the real deal
those are the ones that make it so they
can do their creation and so look man
I'm just yeah yeah okay I'm a celebrity
chef but I got my prep cooks and they
they work their ass off all right yeah
the prep cooked is sort of the verbally
abused wife in the relationship yes I
remember from my my days
the restaurant they would always be
getting yelled at they were it's never
quick enough I was one of those guys
yeah yeah
agree agree all right so you know what
you're always working last time I saw
you I saw you at the LA forum on the
last Slayer show their farewell show was
you Primus and and I can't believe I
missed what's-his-face doing all the
Pantera songs Phil uh Hummel and Sam oh
yeah I've missed it it played such a
quick set I was back there saying hello
and then I came running out I forget as
I ran out somebody else came running
then going did you see that yeah the
whole tour was awesome but it was like a
quick [ __ ] in the parking lot before the
show it was like it was real quick and
that was like what happened and then you
go into the show and you don't know what
the [ __ ] happened but either way Phil
just like set the stage with this
kinetic energy of just like it was like
a quick [ __ ] in the parking lot it was
really cool I mean I think that that was
probably smart because I would imagine
he's probably setting up for a bigger
tour or something like that maybe him
and Rex get back together I hope so
I hope those buzzer golden yeah I can't
kind of do - so let's talk about as I
move oh my back's [ __ ] up so I gotta
say I gotta sit like this here so what
um with you this first single like how
does it how is it done now when you go
to because you're still an album guy but
is it now you gotta like sort of just
see if you could come up with ten new
songs is it better to release one at a
time now or do you put it all out at
once or just give the teaser no I pay no
attention to formats but the thing is is
that he's a you look so mainstream
that's really surprising I look to the
mainstream
I'm kidding [ __ ] hold on let me get my
vape stick okay cool all right there we
go
I'm missing the malls of America so I
need to see no no I don't care about
format but but the thing is we we set
out to do an album and we were trying to
get it done by the time we went on this
I don't know whatever 90th anniversary
tour of something we did you know galaxy
far away a long time ago in July and we
were all set for that and we were hearse
for that but in the meanwhile we started
the new record and and we did a couple
songs and this was one of them and and
we actually played it were rehearsing we
were gonna like actually sneak it into
like the the nostalgia tour of July and
sneak this one in but it came out really
damn good we just kept recording which
is what we're doing now I mean
quarantined to me I mean the only bad
thing about quarantine to me is just the
lack of hockey but other than that I
mean it's just it's just what we do we
just I was gonna ask you how you were
surviving because you you're like one of
the biggest hockey specifically
Blackhawks fans in fact when I talk to
you you talk hockey so how are you
handling this this Boyd well it's it's
actually been okay so far but I'm
running out of choices like I watched
the 72 World Cup I've watched I've
watched all the old stuff on all that
and it's getting sparse now they're
doing like playoff games between Calgary
and Edmonton and ninety-six and I'm just
like no I saw a great documentary
I can't remember the name it was on Bob
Probert 24 for the Hawks and read
Linton's penalty minutes later just like
a great fighter and cocaine addict
education is going score and 129th olds
who could beat the [ __ ] out of the whole
league like it was I mean can you
imagine having that as your title is
like not only did I score 29
but I beat the [ __ ] on the whole league
that is almost MVP word it's an amazing
one of the coolest thing is is when he
makes the all-star team and you know -
this was like the second Golden Age of
the NHL so in the locker room is like
Messier Gretzky Mario Lemieux and all of
that stuff and Yzerman tells
well I guess Mario was with the the
Wales conference but all the guys in the
Campbell conference all those huge huge
guys Yzerman they had like audio of him
doing the eulogy at pro Bert's funeral
and said the funny thing is they all
wanted to meet
Probert so they all say hey can you
introduce me to the big fella cuz they
not only they respected him but I like
my head I'd be like maybe I can get the
guy to like me a little bit so if he
does decide to punch me in the face it's
just sort of a jab and not one of those
haymakers but it was just like you
should see a man because it kind of
combines a lot of [ __ ] that robo you
were into it's like hockey total rebel
motorcycle guy like mue don't have me
because he really enjoyed I got to meet
him one time oh you did yeah yeah at a
Hawks game when he was like an alumni
that came like what we call the
backstage area which it's like this
little bar at Hawks games that you know
like 4 X players and stuff that I'm
allowed to go in and oh basically he
told me like it really was the WWE
before the WWE were like he knew he had
to put on a show almost like getting a
goal was like a cherry on the sundae
that night the main thing was to get
under the heads and skin of the other
team and beat the crap out of somebody
and it's old-school stuff I mean
obviously you know a slapshot fan I'm
sure you are
yeah it kind of brings you back to those
days but yeah Probie was one of a kind
man he was both an age I thought that
was the Golden Age of hockey as far as
like there was never an era where the
balance was perfect of some of the
greatest gold scores of all time and
some of the greatest enforcers of all
time like he
definitely he's the Wayne Gretzky Mario
Lemieux of enforcers like he's he's the
benchmark of them I think as far as what
I've watched on you know there's a bunch
of documentaries about it but that's one
of the the best ones because it also
gets into him as like a dad you know
once he got cleaned up and everything
like it even seemed when he was like
using his stuff he was just a really
like a big teddy bear until he went out
like laced him up and stuff he just
seemed like a great guy he wasn't the
kind of guy that would like if you met
him at a bar like I did like he wouldn't
like want to start a fight and be
ridiculous but he understood his role
right but but really you can't go to
like he was the like primate for that
the template Gordie Howe for an enforcer
and a goal scorer so that that guy you
can't you can't put Probert and mad but
like still he was pretty glad I got
asked the question then Gordie Howe up
against probe I can't see Gordie losing
though cuz he it's like trying to beat
up your dad or something beats a crap
only doctor how scored three or four
goals on his mind defending him so it
would be like a okay I won the fight but
we lost the game kind of thing Gordie
Howe never looked all to me he just
started looking more and more like Lee
Marvin Gordie Howe was like William
Burroughs to me it's like I met him to
an assignee I actually went to like a
hockey signing where you line up like
cattle and you have to pay five bucks to
like get an autograph but like what a
poppy dqr this is so cool no I'm such a
hockey geek man because play goalie so I
used to have projectiles fling dip me
and like well back in the high school
days about 80 miles an hour and still
just like stop what are you doing man
it's like this is no way to make a
living and so I went into music but
originally hockey goalie was my thing
but like
I understand like the intensity of the
[ __ ] game and and Gordie Howe was
like you know everyone talked about all
the flashy players now but he was just
like this this guy that was he looked 60
when he was 20 and he looks 60 when he
was 60 it was kind of a nice thing
Burroughs was the same way where he
looked 80 when he was 20 and he still
looked 80 when he was 80 so I got a tip
the cap to people like that why we were
talking about I mean a comic we're
joking about that how old people looked
back in the day like I watch a lot of me
TV and stuff and like I was just I was
looking at you know I watched The
Hustler okay and I was looking at George
George see Scott he looked like he was
in his 50s in that movie and that decade
he was like 33 and then I looked at a
picture myself when I will it was 33 I
look like I you know it just got out of
high school with skim and rocks I look
like this dope like George C Scott
looked like he had been around the world
like five times had seen it all and
already had like sage advice it's
unbelievable how [ __ ] old it is it
just I don't is it moisturizing and in
just staying inside playing video games
I don't know what it is but like people
look [ __ ] old as [ __ ] back then
you're onto the moisturizing thing I'm
really under the genes thing I'm into
crisper
I think CRISPR is gonna sell this Corona
thing and I think it's gonna solve the
people that look old fast and the people
that look old when they're too young
either way I think it's genetic but like
yeah
George C Scott looked the same in dr.
Strangeglove as he did in Patton and
they had to do makeup to look older and
Patton and he still looks the same I
mean there's a 20-year difference where
he didn't age and I go back to William
Burroughs with that and I think heroin
kept him pickled to the point where he
missed 40 years of his like genetic life
aging so where he was
till sixty at sixty when he was sixty at
twenty I don't know it's a kind of weird
thing that maybe science needs to like
check in to oh I have noticed that
people who really abuse heroin early in
their life are like shredded into their
70s they have like ABS pickle they're
all cut
we're pickled is that what it is we're
pickled if you put a cucumber and
vinegar it'll stay good for a long time
you put a 20 year old on heroin and
vinegar wait what are we promoting here
I think I think we're going the wrong
way something I was supposed to be
promoting your new single and now we're
promoting like listen you can do your
Botox you can do your lotion but I'm
telling you where it's at you're
brushing your teeth and you like what
you look like start doing heroin because
you're gonna look that way to you 70 at
the end of the day that's probably more
important than my new single yes we'll
be keeping people alive which is more
than this administration's doing so I'm
doing my part
I actually have empathy for anybody in
political office right now because dude
I mean I would even think you you being
a band leader trying to just get four
other guys to all pull in the same
direction like as much as Trump is
talking about like alluding to the fact
that he bangs models while is a fan
Demick going on which is just like a WWE
character as much as he's doing that
like I'm finally seeing like this people
getting construction done on my street
I'm finally seeing the construction
workers wearing masks this is the
hilarious thing the the guys got the
mast down around his neck the other guy
has it up on his head and they're still
within six feet shooting the [ __ ] and I
just think there's there's too many
people that choose their own comfort in
the moment versus the good of everybody
in the long run in like I don't think a
Democrat a Republican I think anybody
could could get anybody this just just
too many what what are these [ __ ]
conspiracy theorists
which I am one directive you're out
there protesting having a [ __ ] stay
home and it's like the government wants
you on the wheel they want you running
if you're not making any [ __ ] money
you don't have any money they can't
exploit you anymore they don't want you
at home amen
here check out this david icke video i
just saw like two days ago in my
quarantine playlist this is a really
good one now david icke i don't know if
you know him do you know this guy this
English guy very like a big football
star in England you know like on
Division one team Premier League this
and that and then he went off his rocker
as they say like 20 years ago and and he
brought up some lives do you remember
the name of that we're gonna send it to
you but either way it's just like yeah
okay this is a way for government to
control their it's like a trial run to
see like how we control people in the
event of crisis and see how we can do it
so yeah I'm income into conspiracy
theories but here's the deal you need to
do that I mean you do need to control it
like there has to be some sort of
control or else you just have 7 billion
people running around doing whatever the
[ __ ] they want to do it but Russia and
and and Trump has basically made it so
government what they say means nothing
what they do means everything and what
we say and what our media pounces on is
what they say and what they say is
[ __ ] all of this Trump's right it's
all fake news it's fake news from the
media it's fake news from him it's fake
news from everyone you really have to
start like putting together the pieces
yourself yet we have no education so how
are you supposed to like figure out the
filters on processing all this
information if you answer it's the
perfect forum for a meltdown man I have
the answer oh you stop watching it and
you just put on me too
me and you just act like it isn't
happening I'd never even heard of me TV
until last week and now that's all I've
been watching maybe I'm desperate but
like that's it me TV is the thing and
I'm just I'm going back to like when
time seemed like normal even though they
worried yeah are they worried but like
they seem normal right I'm sitting there
looking in LA watching adam-12 they had
an episode where for whatever 12 is what
I've been watching you see this is
awesome
did you see the one where they were at
LAX [ __ ] Alerus they're in LAX in the
early 70s when it still was only one
level and for whatever reason they see
video of this guy breaking into a car
and one of the Lots so then they get on
like these police mopeds
Lionel's motorcycles so small they were
like the original mopeds and they ride
over to go get those guys and I'm just
sitting there looking at like how quaint
lax used to look but then in my head I'm
going like wait a minute right like this
is like four years after Martin Luther
King was assassinated Vietnam is going
on and all that but you're watching on
TV it's like this was a simpler time in
LA no that's why it's get into some of
the old dragnets when they arrest
psychedelic users there's about three or
four those those are mind blowing oh
that's awesome yeah yeah please go go
from adam-12 to dragnet and this is like
this is like a continuance this is like
a rebirth of LA to me between Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood and then like being
quarantined in having to watch old LA
shows I really feel more Angelino than
I've ever felt my life watch you watch
Peter Gunn I watched almost every
episode of that I have never seen a guy
like he gets knocked out every [ __ ]
episode like the CTE this guy must have
had and I'm talking like pistol to the
back of the head every other [ __ ]
episode
it's I don't know III got it totally got
into that show I got into 77 Sunset
Strip for a while and now I'm starting
to move up to like maybe Maddux or
something like that because they have
all of that [ __ ] on there but lately
I've been watching yeah Adam Schwab what
kills me is as long as I've been out
here I can never recognize where they
are in LA because it's just it's just
changed so much they've I mean I guess
it was you know close to 50 years ago
but the level of [ __ ] that they've just
you know well listen when we get to like
having to resort to watch all Mannix
reruns then it I think it's time to like
lift the curfew
what they're gonna do is they'll get
like a screening thing that's gonna work
and then they're gonna let people you're
gonna have to have the right mask in
gloves and you just be able to [ __ ]
go to everybody just is gonna you know
walk around looking like they're ready
to do surgery for a while yeah they do
that in Asia all the time don't they I
remember in 1980s it's no different it's
okay if it's okay to wear gloves
shout out to Asian people like they have
been on point with this with glove and
mast [ __ ] and in like the [ __ ]
anytime I see somebody you know we're
not wearing a mask it's never that Asian
people are just if we would all do what
the [ __ ] they're doing this [ __ ] would
be over or at least it's the same thing
they did during World War two they have
to be extra exemplary citizens because
of public perception I feel bad for like
the rap that they're getting because a
few people sold pangolins and bats in a
[ __ ] market in Beijing and they
should just stop that we don't have that
here we don't have that anywhere else
just stop all the crazy like exotic game
trading and and I think that will help
it's not gonna solve it but I think that
that virus has come and go and now we
need to deal with this but I think
people need to be smart
I don't think protesting with
Confederate flags and going you know
don't tread on me freedom or die kind of
[ __ ] it's just like that's the way to
solve this
I don't know but that's that's why I
have empathy for any administration
right now because that all it takes is
one of those [ __ ] idiots to keep the
thing going and to try to corral all of
it it's like you know it's like when you
unbox something and they got those
stupid peanuts in there it's just over
yeah it's gonna be em they're gonna get
everywhere and as much as you try to
vacuum em all up you're gonna in six
months now you're gonna find one
underneath the couch I just put them on
my thought at this point I don't I just
want to see if they spring something in
my anal track to start sticking them up
there and see what happens I mean this
anal peanut thing is just has to go what
is that to go No
stop sending me peanuts oh I thought of
trying to eat them I put them up my butt
I put them in my hair made a Christmas
tree there's just too many peanuts
peanuts on every Amazon thing that comes
to my house I have peanuts coming
literally out of my orifices bring them
down to the [ __ ] the local place and
they'll take them that packs up [ __ ] I'm
supposed to drive to go drive my peanuts
down to a local peanut thank you okay
okay I'll go online as soon as wealthier
but I want to know where these peanut
factories are because they send way too
many peanuts ugh you just found my like
one big I wasn't expecting to talk about
this today but I'm gonna talk about it
now I'm pissed these peanut things have
to go what are they and they're a menace
to your house to your home too I'm sure
they're gonna find a lot of other things
wrong with them enough with the peanuts
they have to stop stop ordering [ __ ] man
you're ordering too much [ __ ] if you go
to a [ __ ] store you don't get it
first of all can we go back to the fact
I mean you said anal peanut I actually
thought that was a thing because there
cuz there was kids but he drugs in a
liquid form unlike a [ __ ] q-tip or
something or a tampon and sticking it in
their ass at raves so I figured all
right maybe the peanut people caught on
to that
sorry that's just what I thought I don't
know yeah it might be a conspiracy but I
think there are about two conspiracies
too late man there there's all sorts of
[ __ ] things that they're sending us
that are like completely unhealthy and
unwise and and and they still do it and
we accept it okay but I'm putting my
foot down on peanuts right now because I
think we've had enough other things sent
to us that your only choice is to stop
ordering stuff and they know you need
this stuff al you need it you need it
there why do you have all these [ __ ]
peanuts man what why do you keep
ordering [ __ ] okay then I think that we
should all invest in 3d printers and get
3d printers sent to us and then we can
print our own [ __ ] then we don't have to
have it shipped just a thought well wait
a minute if it's on a piece of paper you
don't need peanuts right I thought you
were ordering something that they didn't
want it to break now they put peanuts
and everything man everything everything
it's a psyche what is wrong with you I
have never this is like the greatest
[ __ ] rant ever I've never seen like
of all the things that get upset with no
I'm pissed yeah okay I was trying to
tone it down I'm trying to bring it back
down here now which is your favorite
guitar on the wall one get you off the
peanuts subject here which one has the
most hits in it your number one starter
to start a series set the [ __ ] tone
which acts are you pulling off the wall
I hate playing [ __ ] guitar I don't
have a favorite I mean there's a bunch
of things that do different things but I
actually have a favorite bass guitar I'm
more of a bass player so are you like
yeah I mean if you could think of like
Tom and Slayer I'm more like the kind of
singer bass player dude but like
occasionally they make me play guitar
and keyboards and stuff like that
so yeah I don't have you know my
favorite is is like
having my music be known enough that
like bill burr calls me on a Sunday
that's now I'm famous no no no if I'm
calling you I don't know if you might
have just got fired from your label or
something oh they actually they're
really happy with me right now because
this new single I just did this song
that like we're supposed to be doing an
album and I was supposed to be getting
it done by a like big July tour in the
States and and that's not gonna happen
but we we got a couple songs done and I
send it to them and just go like look
you're not just sending me money and I'm
just doing coke I'm actually doing stuff
and so I sent him the songs and they
went like woah this song's awesome and
so this song gets released and I've got
other songs I mean I'm gonna now I don't
know of our July tour is gonna be done I
don't see how that's gonna happen unless
it some some weird stuff happens like
for instance like I thought that July
tour would happen because Trump is such
a man baby that he wants a 4th of July
parade in his honor signifying triumph
over Kovach 19 4th of July parade tour
started like July 2nd or some and so I
figured he'd open it up to everyone so
people could mass adore him on how he
conquered the virus I mean I don't know
what this guy's mind is at this point
because I don't like four-year-olds that
much but like that's the kind of thing
that I thought but then I see where it's
just like well okay we're gonna open but
nobody over a thousand people can be
like brought out and Taylor Swift just
canceled I'm no Taylor Swift you know
but I'm just saying it's just like that
nobody over a thousand and our tours
were over a thousand so I'm thinking
like wow this is weird so I don't know
what no but either way I'm just gonna
stay in the studio and I'm just gonna
keep recording stuff and I'm just going
keep doing good stuff and observing like
social interactions and writing music
about it and just taking the polaroid
snapshot of what's going on and and hope
for the best because that's all we can
all do well there you go
will you stay you're staying productive
I know I get a kick out of Donald Trump
that's the only way I can look at it I
just like this is like if Ron Burgundy
was suddenly like president that thing
like I don't believe you I don't know
what you're talking about good show good
show everybody good stuff all the way
around yeah I just I can't like I can't
watch CNN I can't watch Fox News I just
can't I can't [ __ ] it you know the other
yesterday I went for it every three days
we go for a dry I stay at the house
every three days we get in the car we go
for a drive so go before you drive what
do you drive
what do I Drive I Drive my turn I'm out
what nowhere dude up because me and Liz
like we do like a Topanga Canyon and all
the offshoots drive at least once twice
a week oh we're uh we're Big Valley
people in Mulholland Drive oh yeah we do
Mahalo
all right I'm sorry I'm quarantined
drive together
yeah I go up there you know drive around
that's who we do yeah so I've been doing
that and so we get on we put the radio
on and you know at this point who
doesn't know what's going on in between
every [ __ ] song they gotta bring up
you know during these strange times you
know we're gonna be playing music during
you know these uncertain times they just
keep I got like anxiety I finally just
shut it off I was like Mia can they just
[ __ ] play music I get it it's
uncertain I get it people are losing
money I get it old people are dying I
just wanted like five [ __ ] minutes I
can't do anything about this [ __ ] I'm
trying to listen to some easy listen to
music and you're [ __ ] telling me that
the whole world economy is crashing
between each one acting like you're my
friend you know it's like if I I've
visited friends into the hospital who
died in a cancer I don't bring up their
[ __ ] cancer every 10 seconds you know
I just wanted to come by and say hello
during your dying of pancreatic cancer
nice flowers that you got because
say goodbye to Patrick Swayze but
wouldn't so what I don't understand is
I've been doing this for like 30 years
I'm the chicken little of rock man
the sky was is always falling with me
and yet we're still friends
you just said like I'm tired of this
[ __ ] but you know I used to be you I
used to be you and I wore my friends out
they were like dude I can't listen this
Federal Reserve [ __ ] anymore and I
realized what I was doing was I was just
saying a bunch of terrifying [ __ ] with
no solution and all they do was sit down
and have a couple of beers and I had to
stand back and be like I am a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so I can't look at it like Trump like
this guy's a complete [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then look at the previous
administration with Obama and like if
you really listen to the people on the
other side of those drone bombs I mean
he exact he wasn't exactly a [ __ ]
saint either and then they're out doing
the [ __ ] speech tour and making all
their money too so it's kind of like
they're all doing the same things fools
they are all [ __ ] yeah I mean you
can go way back from starting all right
let's go with just start with Truman but
I don't even get me started on like the
Grover Cleveland McKinley this this age
I'm a history major this particular one
is pretty bad but Trump is the thing I
admire about Trump is his Overton
ascending it's its overt and there's no
hiding it it's just like he reminds me
did you ever see Outlaw Josey Wales
of course yeah okay that snake all
salesmen that eventually turns Josey
Wales in like a $2 for the snake oil
when trumps got stopped invested into
this chloroquine and sure which has been
proved to cause heart attacks it's only
for malaria and extreme doesn't happen
doesn't have good business instincts how
can you ruin a casino a casino is a
money
maker and he's gone bankrupt on casinos
and he's our president and now he's
trying to do this drug that's gonna cure
[ __ ] and have Jerrod and charge of
everything which is a slumlord in
Baltimore in New York which is like
under investigate I mean the people he
puts in charge of stuff and now all of
his like knuckleheads are like fire foul
Chi fire foul he in Michigan and
Louisiana and all these places with this
and is it's a it's an artificial turf
Tea Party kind of Koch brothers I
brought my brother said the best thing
about politics as far as Democrats and
Republicans he goes that's like rooting
for the AFC or the NFC and in the end of
the day they're all in the NFL and I'm
just saying yeah that's exactly how I
look at it you know Trump says you know
he's a specific sort
he's a reason real original I gotta tell
you that guy has changed the [ __ ]
game you saw like I mean I didn't watch
a lot of it but some of those democratic
debates they were all doing what the
[ __ ] he did four years ago when it was
crazy where they were just completely
ignoring the rules you know what's
dangerous about him is that by his
success it allows people like Oprah to
be our next president or like dr. oz or
Phil or anyone that like has enough air
time that seems to know what they're
talking about and they don't know [ __ ]
about because there's Jesse Ventura
Arnold Schwarzenegger and there's been a
lot of celebrities that have become
mayors of small towns and they just kept
going higher Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan
you know did a movie with a monkey next
thing you know he's governor of
California and then he's present for you
so now all those work out huh this I
look at it the only like human being
that's been president in my lifetime
that I remember is Jimmy Carter and the
proof is in the pudding with what this
guy this guy's in his 90
he's still building houses for the
homeless everybody else Democrat
Republican went on the speech tour I
mean even Obama's wife is out there with
the glitter hooker boots is out there
doing an arena tour yeah teller [ __ ]
book yeah we tried to open for hilarious
[Laughter]
yeah I just think it's um it's pretty
overt as far as like where I don't know
and then but then I also try just to
keep my sanity I try to have empathy for
wherever is president because especially
since Bill Clinton from Bill Clinton on
every president including Bill Clinton
has just been trying not to get
impeached and thrown out of the office
it's like they can't even [ __ ] do the
job [ __ ] they go at the George Bush
told Alexis told election well it's
[ __ ] over
no he's president we're forgetting
you're blocking out like eight years of
Obama no drama
did we have this kind of like headline
news cycle 24 hours a day of new what
are you talking about out we have that
yeah her big thing was that he wore
white after Memorial Day are brown on I
mean come on man I mean the guy who was
just as sold-out as everyone else but at
least he didn't cause drama I'm kind of
kind of tired of just like the cycle of
drama of drama of drama when I go to bed
at night I'm thinking about it when I
wake up enough I didn't have to do that
with Obama this we need a plane we need
a cool year break we need a for your
break man and if it takes like that
senile [ __ ] useless job I need to
[ __ ] get us four years of sleep I'm
happy I tell you something
you can have a four-year break the
second you stop watching this [ __ ]
okay and what I think what happened with
during Obama was there was this level
off period of people being numb to the
fact that we're in these never-ending
Wars that are bankrupting the country I
also think probably a lot of your
friends leaned left so the white noise
was because ever since you know when
Obama was in office out here in
Hollywood he could do no [ __ ] wrong
he walked on water and blah blah blah
blah blah now I do an acting gig you
know it's not as bad now but when Trump
first came in it was at a [ __ ]
funeral out here but I bet if if
Hollywood was in Nebraska everybody
would've been doing a jig and going to
work would have been fun during those
times so I just think you know if you
live in LA you live in an AFC city if
the Democrats are the AFC yep that no
Nebraska is not really happy about their
governor the Republican governor and
their president right now and Republican
policies right now just because it's
affecting everyday people and all sudden
they see that like this ideological like
demagogue that you just want to like
make it easy
root for somebody that's bigger than
life and they'll take care of it like a
superhero like a Marvel comic it's not
reality now they're starting to deal
with the realities of it and I just
think that like um even even his own
cult of personality is not going to be
able to withstand like truthful
logistical things that are happening
right now you can't [ __ ] your way
out of X amount of people dead X amount
of people needing bail ventilators when
they're not there you can't wait out of
that you absolutely can that's what they
have Fox News for and they'll blame
something that someone with the blue tie
did the same way is if there was a blue
tie guy in they would have blamed the
red tie guy before I agree with you I
agree with you on that no there is no
getting around this this is fact this is
fact you can you can spend resolve that
it's Hillary Clinton
fault that the this virus is here no no
you have to deal in fact now because
it's affecting our everyday life we
can't go out on the beach I may have to
meet you on Mulholland Drive for like
some kind of mass glob to thing to like
say hello to you on driving down the
street I mean really that you got to
deal with it don't you think the
combination of aviation and us hacking
down the [ __ ] rainforest I mean this
was inevitable of course it's inevitable
so it's it's it's it's not a red tie guy
or a blue tie guy and get back up but
but why are those policies there that
are hacking down the Amazon bolson are
oh and Brazil and all the other
right-wing Li president makes less money
reading Hume view that that's what
they're doing they're trying to make it
like so business can get one last profit
windfall and [ __ ] everyone else because
then they have their mansions and they
can go retire in a bubble proof
underground cave and leave everyone for
themselves and that's what's going on I
thought you like conspiracy theories
this is a left-wing conspiracy theory
this is like the right-wing what I like
at all the money that can and go
underground and leave us all to [ __ ]
be upstairs yeah what I like at this
point in my life is just shutting off
all of that [ __ ] noise because
there's nothing I can do about it
there's nothing I can do about like the
level of bloodshed like there would have
to be a legit revolution to get all of
the stuff that needs to the very few
people that are making these decisions
to keep these old ways of making money
or whatever going the level of power and
weaponry at their disposal you know it's
not like the old days like you know when
we got sick in England where everybody
grabs a musket out of their [ __ ]
house and hides behind a tree and shoots
a guy in a red coat like I don't know
how to I I went down the thing like I
think conspiracy theory gets a bad rap
as far as everybody goes to like oh you
think the shapeshifters
and the moons made out of cheese like
like that's what's used to define
conspiracy theories like you're always
defined by your worst like comedians
that you know have lampshades on their
heads we're on off stage you know the
sad clown but bla bla bla bla bla but I
just think like I don't like I went down
that whole road
I saw how [ __ ] up things were and I
just don't like okay so you have all
that information you know all that you
believe all that how do you mobilize a
bunch of people the same way the
government's trying to mobilize people
during this [ __ ] pandemic to just
wear masks and gloves and they can't
even get him to do that how the [ __ ] you
gonna mobilize people to all be like you
know what I'll figured it out now let's
[ __ ] go do this it'll drive you mad
no no I don't I don't want people to go
L figured it out I want people to go I
figured it out and here it is it's
called education and like getting
through fake news and through the from
bard meant that we have of left white
ring news that are like inundating our
minds and souls yes
I mean seriously is this like just youth
common [ __ ] sense right now with this
virus spreading at one person to like
ten people potentially every time you're
in contact with somebody and you have
like these right-wing protests Gretchen
Whitmer Richford
[ __ ] that was a Freudian slip Gretchen
Whitmer of Michigan said the best in
just like okay that's great we all
wanted to be open but you just made it
harder to be open by getting all
together 1 or 2 3 4 10 20 50 of you were
infected in there maybe not even knowing
it and now you've just spread it wider
so what am I supposed to do it's full
right those protestors up you stick him
in a [ __ ] gymnasium and you leave
them there for two weeks and he gets it
they spread it you don't [ __ ] treat
them right ok
I'm with you I'm with you on that just
don't treat them you want to be selfish
mouth-breather I mean I don't I don't
know I don't know let's let's uh listen
I don't know what the [ __ ] I respect
your opinions I don't know [ __ ] I don't
even watch energy kidding so my big
thing is I'm trying to clean up my
[ __ ] little man cave here it's a
[ __ ] mess I shrink-wrapped a bunch of
[ __ ] to shove under a bed and if I can
just get some of my photos up on the
wall you know I'd say this pandemic was
a success um this pandemic is not a
success because I'm my next question to
you is how do you do it without hockey
dude I got I'm in this scary [ __ ]
place where I don't miss anything
anymore this this whole thing has become
my new reality I wake up in the morning
I make my wife and kid breakfast I play
with my daughter and then you know when
she goes down for her nap I go out into
the garage I work on being able to play
good times bad times because I feel like
that's gonna make me a happy person and
then I work on a script and then my
daughter wakes up and I get up with her
and then that's when she gets up at 4:00
that's the end of my day we play for an
hour and a half then it's dinner time
and then there's the after-dinner crazy
energy and then there's the bath and
then there's the you know getting her
ready for bed pajamas brushing the teeth
and all of that and then I got to read
her two or three books and by then it's
like 8:30 9:00 o'clock and I am [ __ ]
wiped out and that's just become my life
I don't miss anything that I ever used
to do it's it felt like it literally
feels like it never happened
that's heavy man tonight I understand
that's heavy [ __ ] yeah I don't know
anything of the best I don't like I and
I am I have what I've always wanted
which is be able to stay home and I have
this crazy awesome time with my daughter
every day I bet her now she bats Lefty I
can under hand the ball
all in like like two out of ten she can
hit and like that that to me is like
killing on stage it's the greatest thing
and I'm watching all these Disney shows
with her I'm teaching her how to draw
the other day I she counted backwards
from ten you know she's three that's
like a big deal
and uh you know she's three now so that
initial brain I guess of her personality
is developed and she's so like
emotionally open that the other day I
well you know I was on the computer and
she came in and she said dad dad that
can we watch popcorn a movie tonight I
just kind of nodded not listening so she
went out to the kitchen and said mama
dad I said I can watch you know you know
popcorn in a movie and my wife came out
why did you say that you can't you can't
do that cuz I forget why she couldn't so
then she found out she couldn't she
cried she came to she was like dad I
asked you and you you went like this and
I was like I know buddy I'm sorry I
wasn't paying attention
totally validated what she was thinking
she gave me a big hug kiss and then
walked out in the kitchen and said dad
do I want to do that again
she wanted to reenact the apology it was
so like wow that's hairy yeah I'll tell
you what's great about that is that's
what the [ __ ] I didn't was not available
when I was growing up which is the
source of so much of flipping out over
nothing cuz I just feel like I'm not
gonna be heard so like I got more
satisfaction out of that than doing my
last special at Royal Albert Hall which
was my best work I feel like that's
literally like that's yeah I believe you
man I mean that is what you want to
leave behind it's not your body of work
oh look at me telling the jokes it's the
people that you created with the help of
God don't want to piss anybody off right
that you [ __ ] that they're these good
open people that have empathy that want
to help and want to listen like like
that's your job as a parent and then you
have to have that weird duality of also
don't take any [ __ ] and end up in the
trunk of somebody's car so you got a
that's where the jujitsu is gonna come
in when she gets
listen we're look at it I mean that
that's a beautiful story and and I'll
give you one on top of that not not as
good as that but like my 32 year old
daughter in Seattle we talk more now
than we have in last 20 years and she's
in an essential job
she runs a pharmacy a holistic pharmacy
in Seattle one of ground zeroes and
she's in there every day and we talk
more now than than I ever have
with her this is this is really kind of
cool in a lot of ways and I think it's
kind of cool in a lot of ways in that
the world really needed this time out so
the people that are screaming and waving
Confederate flags and brandishing their
guns and marching state capitals and
going we have to open right now
maybe you are you ought to think about
like this might actually be a teaching
moment and a good thing and I hate to
use the word teaching moment it's so
liberal and so wishy-washy but it's just
like it really is like take the time to
realize like there's some actual good
that can come out of this man I mean
I've seen it is I just there's just a
few things like you know if you're
living week to week those are the people
that I have empathy for as far as like
let's get this [ __ ] thing going again
I think this is not cool this
government's come in and this is where
Wall Street government does not really
work over Main Street government we need
to keep the the economy going and the
way to do that is to make sure that the
workers are healthy and right now they
just want profit and they don't care
about the workers being healthy and this
is not cool so we need to find a middle
ground on that what's good about this
podcast is we didn't agree with each
other on all of it but at no point that
we start screaming and yelling so I
would I would hope that we could get
back to that Andrew just popped up so I
think we're coming towards the end what
do we got to do here okay LegalZoom
everybody
health and safety is on the top of
everyone's minds right now no matter
what happens you want to make sure your
loved ones are protected
that's why LegalZoom continues to
provide a reliable way everyone to set
up right a state plan without leaving
your home it starts with finding the
answers to your questions do you need a
last will and testament or a living
trust speak about importance of having
your affairs in order
yes if you've created more people if you
have a wife or a husband if you kick the
bucket the only thing they should have
to worry about is the pain of losing you
other than that they should be rolling
in dough like they just you know hit
both showcases on The Price is Right
what about an advanced health care
directive and what about what's a power
of attorney thankfully you don't have to
figure these things out on your own
legal zooms online resources make it
easier to get started and if you get to
speak to an attorney their independent
attorney network is there to guide and
advise you Legal Zoom isn't a law firm
so you won't have to worry about
expensive billable hours adding up take
an important step for you and your
family today go to legalzoom.com to get
started on a last will living trust and
more or find out how you can speak to an
attorney fronted for advice on the right
estate plan Legal Zoom where life meets
legal and shine going today there bill
hello thank you I try to always make
sure being a Baldy that I have nice
overhead lighting so it looked like I
just played full court basketball are we
inside one of your motorhomes or is that
your home
now we're in the studio this is what I
do like about this pandemic is all you
guys are gonna be making more music look
at ya yeah yeah boy less what are you
doing man
you what making record sounds wretched
sounds for the masses yeah like I'm
almost almost done with the problem man
just like this this this quarantine
thing is great outside of the obvious
new drink of vodka vermouth and an
emergency fizzy pack and then shaken not
stirred that's a Korn Feeny I've been
doing
and then of course like you know doing
your your shrooms your daily shrooms in
a little gel cap you buy an ounce and
you make it into like about 50 pills and
you do those and then and then since
it's essential the weed stores are open
California quarantine is way better than
I think maybe Alabama quarantine or some
but they didn't quarantine so you know
you can still go to your gun shop I
guess yeah but they don't let me fit
they don't let you fish it
I can't ocean fish I'm not supposed to
go to my boat now or get out on the
ocean why the rule why you know they
said no no bueno they said sorry Charlie
Charlie stay we'll stay away from look
if you go out in your boat alone what do
you mean I did I went out the other day
and everybody they say that's not good
it they said no that's not supposed to
do that well what are you gonna give it
to the fish yes well you know those
dolphins have raped a few people have
and a so maybe if they get a hold of
less they rub up against them you know
unless is too ashamed to share his story
I think oh I wouldn't be ashamed to
share that story I'd share that story
right with you yeah I mean I could see
less going down to flog reporting a
dolphin orgy but not not in where do you
living in Oregon or northern Cal you
live in northern Cal northern California
but thank you babe oh no the Dolphins
are cool he's not gonna molest dolphins
bill it's okay yeah he won't be worried
no less was the victim in that story yes
do tell all right well we actually
worked we're down to the end of this
here less do you have anything to
promote see you later
we've been yapping 50 minutes trying to
solve the world's problems it took me a
while to get on the damn thing I tried
getting on and they Lee
because they didn't recognize my my
pseudonym my nom de plume so well all
right my podcast listeners less has been
slowly talking me in to buying a
Motorhome I'm actually in I just got to
get the wife to to to sign off on it but
my thing is I like those GMC ones
remember the one from stripes that's the
one I like yes II am 50 I found you a
couple you haven't gentleman's listen
you know she won't let me get a gun I
can't get a [ __ ] Motorhome you know
I'm trying I'm trying my damnedest to be
a good American they have a gun yeah
motor horny look we had a went berserk
and drive down the street with his gun
in his motor home yeah I'm your GMC I'll
find you one now's the time and there's
bargains to be had right now I'm
actually looking for another bus oh you
are my thing is I like the one the they
call ed the Palm Desert whatever they
call it that green one that lime green
with the lamp checkered interior that's
that's the one that I want so well you
know you have a link to the people in
fact you're on your link to the people
right now you can put the word out to
somebody send one your way how am I
gonna put that thing I live in Los
Angeles right now you say have you guys
ever watched Breaking Bad your mobile
home is a potential meth lab is that
what you guys are doing is that what you
guys are doing what's the pandemic we
need another we need another revenue
stream see what happens see what happens
when les shows up we were talking world
Charlotte Excel we all the Tweaker talk
starts as soon as I show up that's
pretty good i hears them out northern
california in meth and tweaking and
murder mountains and all of that what's
wrong with you people up there les you
know I don't know it's a it's been in my
family since the get-go so I just kind
of try and steer steer clear and I don't
use
my motorhome for for that purpose I
don't have a motor I might have a bus
I'm a pre/post bus I refuse to call it a
Motorhome oh sorry I didn't mean to you
know I know those of trunking wearing
trotting my horns yeah you know there's
pretty much meth everywhere so I know
don't blame me
I wasn't seriously trying to suggest
that Eureka will you live right you're
up in Eureka all the way that's quite a
bit north of me I know
Bodega Bay Area I'm joking I tried to
get a gig up in Eureka and I forget what
the hell happened and then that murder
Mountain thing came out and all my
friends became gumshoes and were somehow
solving all those those [ __ ] murders
or whatever anyway alright well as we
wrap this thing up less I apologize that
it took so long for you to get on by the
way can I thank both of you guys for
that incredible show that I saw at the
LA forum there we go it was amazing it
was murderers row it was Mount Rushmore
of [ __ ] bands and you guys all had
your own lane this is how good that show
was I was 51 years old
I stood up through all of it and was not
tired that's how good that [ __ ] show
us that's pretty good yeah but you
probably have roids and so you couldn't
sit down anyway so you had to stand up
and you enjoyed it because it was good
but I think the fact you didn't sit down
was probably your own internal physical
qualms no you notice I have botoxed feet
I've got all the wrinkles out of him and
I got the padding of the liquid on the
bottom and I was able yeah I was able to
do that had those doctor shows with the
velcro strips hey les what uh al stuff
is coming out on Friday what are you
working on and any release date or
anything like that
well I I was supposed to do a a gig two
nights ago at the Greek Theatre and
Berkeley but it didn't happen
I was yeah we had a big Primus to her
plan we were going to go out and do
Russia's farewell to Kings in its
entirety a tribute to Kings
it's now looking
we're saying do you think even when they
open up live live shows of people even
going to show up I think they're gonna
be [ __ ] packed yes yes they're gonna
be packed and and the thing is is that
July is still weird
I really think my opinion is that
everything will be open by July 4th
because Trump wants a parade for himself
to like show that he's the king of the
covin and that he's killed it and it's
all beautiful and everything's great
Jared fixed it and and this and that and
so I think July 4th they're gonna
actually start letting people back out I
know we have some May 15th deadlines of
like ok certain things can be open it'll
still be weird and all that but I just
think Trump has enough of an ego that
he's gonna open it up July 4th just to
have a parade in his honor and if that
happens then my July 4th tour goes on
because we were scheduled from July 4th
to like mid-august and that might be
possible because if Trump has a parade
then we can have a couple thousand
people at our place but if it doesn't
happen which I'm actually kind of hoping
it doesn't at this point I'm not one of
these militia people Tea Party people
that are like you know Second Amendment
free free us from quarantine this and
that it just makes sense and so we're
fine
that they rescheduled the whole thing
for April in the event that it doesn't
happen in July yeah but I just see Trump
doing something like real kim jung-han
of like I need a parade for me for going
through for this on July 4th and if he
does massive turnouts with rallies and
[ __ ] there's no reason why you can't see
ministry and and literally will hand out
masks and gloves at the door before our
shows and you can come see us as opposed
to a trump rally where you can just go
yell at Biden and
and and do whatever and spread your yeah
[ __ ] if you were in a position of power
in life where you could say they're
gonna have a parade for me wouldn't you
do it you know hard to lay off let's
have a parade for me yeah but but if you
can get the parade approved by Congress
and pandemic or all that if it's
postponed the fact that you just had
your parade in your name is good enough
for me you don't hope it happens have
the proof I hope he has a [ __ ] parade
because then we get back more towards
normal and I hope less you get your so I
hope all you guys help because if you
guys get out there that means I'm
getting out there so I'm rooting for the
president to have as his 4th of July
aren't I awesome parade will I really
just I just want to go to that I want to
go to the AL parade that's that that's
what I'm looking forward to now for it
baby I'm gonna have my own parade
already that's good alright well listen
les I got to have you back on cuz you're
only on for like eight minutes that's
just not acceptable all right and you
actually haven't read I'm not going
anywhere
hey I know all right all right al
Jerguson Les Claypool everybody there
look at they're in their home studios
making more music for everybody
god bless your bedroom there bill yeah I
just have bad posture I could sit up you
know I could look more professional but
then what happens is my giant head makes
this shadow with the overhead light I
kind of pride myself on no production
quality whatsoever it's one of the
charms of the podcast yes podcast yes
sir all right les continued health
continued you know I hope you get to
fish and all of that [ __ ] coming back
I'm out of here later
oh he's going back Oh another day yeah
he's coming back another day
well crashing on your call exactly
alright my kids getting upset when I
gotta go back through bad times
alright you guys thank you
guys for coming thank you to everybody
listening to uh to the Monday morning
podcasts I'm gonna do a little ad right
here al les will see you guys thank you
all right everybody that is the podcast
that was a wild one man I had a great
time am i talking to anybody anymore I
don't even know all right